so Jay I got this new app it's called
Quantum mirror it's Quantum mirror it's
really cool watch this
right that was
weird what have you always had that
goate to
yes am I in the Mirror Universe are you
Mirror Universe
J I don't know what you're
about what's your favorite sport kicking
babies probably what about favorite
holiday Canada okay they're all just
psychos man they're all psychos it's
it's awesome they're the rudest people
you ever meet in your life they're just
glorious they'd rather punch you in the
face and say hello I just I just love
the place terrible Donuts though okay I
still think you miror Universe J uh what
what's your favorite thing about star
game ah well it's obviously the best
show sg1 is obviously the best show um I
just love how they go out there they
find all those kind sweet innocent gods
and shoot him in the face it's just
great okay this apps really weird I'm Li
go
back okay that was really weird I was in
a mirror Universe Michael what would
Daniel Jackson's Mirror Universe
character be like and John you played an
Amazing Mirror Universe character in
Enterprise he was properly evil how much
fun is it to play just a complete psycho
villain like that and what advice could
you give Michael if he was to play an
evil Daniel Jackson guys thank you so
much for inviting us and um have a great
night and Happy
Thanksgiving Happy
Thanksgiving